♪
>> A HUGE ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY
CAME FROM THE PENTAGON.
AMERICAN TROOPS ARE GOING BACK
TO AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE THE
TALIBAN MADE A FIERCE COMEBACK.
THE RED ALL OVER THAT SCREEN AND
AND THIS IT HAPPENED WITHIN 10
DAYS.
THEY HAVE RETAKEN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
THEY FOR CONTROL OF TWO-THIRDS.
THERE ARE CONCERNS THAT THE
TALIBAN COULD TAKE OVER THE
CAPITAL OF KABUL.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
SENDING 3,000 U.S. TROOPS TO GET
THE REMAINING PERSONNEL AT THE
U.S. EMBASSY OUT OF KABUL COMING
MONTHS AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN
ANNOUNCED THE WITHDRAWAL OF U.S.
FORCES FROM THE REGION.
HE SAID YESTERDAY THAT HE HAD NO
REGRETS ABOUT THE DECISION TO
PULL OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
I UNDERSTAND THERE WAS A MEETING
LAST NIGHT AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH THE DEFENSE SECRETARY AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE.
THEY DECIDED THEY WOULD SEND
3,000 TROOPS BACK IN.
WE ARE LEARNING THIS AFTERNOON
THAT KANDAHAR THE SECOND LARGEST
SEASON HAS FALLEN.
ONLY KABUL IS LEFT.
THAT'S WHERE THE U.S. EMBASSY
IS.
BRIAN, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> YOU COVERED IT GREAT ON YOUR
SHOW.
THEY ARE GOING IN NOT TO SAVE
KABUL BUT TO GET OUR PEOPLE OUT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE ULTIMATE
EMBARRASSMENTS OF MY LIFETIME.
WHERE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
IN DELAWARE.
THE SECOND OF DEFENSE DID NOT
APPROVE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
LEAVING THE KURDS NAKED IN
SYRIA.
HE QUIT.
FOR GENERAL AUSTIN TO SERVE AS
LONG AS HE DID AND FOR HIM TO DO
THIS AND FOLLOW ORDERS AND NOT
SPEAK UP IS INEXCUSABLE.
ADMIRAL KIRBY KNOWS BETTER.
HE SAID IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS?
AS WE SPEAK THEY ARE BEING
BURNED ALIVE AND MARRIED OFF TO
THE TALIBAN AND GIVING UP AND
RUNNING FOR THE HILLS.
NOT BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
COURAGE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO LEADERSHIP.
THEIR LEADERS WERE TRAINED.
LEFT THEM AT THE DOORSTEP.
WE LEFT WITHOUT ANY PLAN AND
LEFT IRRESPONSIBLY AND CHINA IS
GIGGLING.
WE LOOK AS BAD AS THE RUSTSIANS
WHEN THEY RAN FOR THE HILLS IN
THE 1980s.
>> THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
GONE THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> WE WENT THERE 20 YEARS AGO.
IT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF HOW WE
ARE LIED TO.
WE WERE TOLD IF WE LEFT ALL OF
THE KURDS WOULD DIE.
WE ARE WAR WARY.
YOU FOR JAIL.
YOU ARE TRYING TO STAY AWAKE.
THE MOMENT YOU FALL ASLEEP
SOMEONE WILL TAKE YOUR SHOES.
DO WE STAY AWAKE FOREVER IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THE PRESENCE CAN BE
TECHNOLOGY.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON, ON THE GROUND.
>> HOW HAVE WE BEEN THERE FOR 20
YEARS AND NOT KNOW WHAT IS ON
THE GROUND?
>> WE LEFT!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WHAT WAS THE MISSION IN THE
FIRST PLACE?
>> BIN LADEN.
>> BUT THE BUILDING OF THE
SCHOOLS AND IT'S A NATIONAL
SECURITY OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA TO HAVE A PRESENCE IN
THAT AREA AND HAVE EYES ON THE
GROUND AND GET THERE QUICKLY.
NOW CHINA AND RUSSIA ARE FILLING
THAT VOID.
CHINA IS WATCHING WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> FOR 100 YEARS PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN GOING INTO AFGHANISTAN.
>> WOULD YOU CALL IT
A RESPONSIBLE WITHDRAWAL?
YOU SPOKE TO SOMEONE WHO CAN'T
BELIEVE WHAT HE IS SEEING ON THE
GROUND RIGHT NOW.
>> YOUR ANALOGY TO VIETNAM IS
THE PERFECT ANALOGY.
SHOULD WE HAVE REMAINED IN
VIETNAM?
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WHAT IF WE LEFT SOUTH KOREA
AND JAPAN?
WHAT WOULD THAT DO TO OUR
INFLUENCE IN THE REGION?
IN 2014 WE STOPPED THE OFFENSIVE
AND WENT ON A SUPPORTING ROLE.
WE HAVEN'T LOST A MAN OR
A WOMAN.
>> THE AFGHAN MILITARY ARE NOT
ABLE TO PUT UP A DEFENSE MEANS
WE WOULD JUST BE THE POLICEMEN
IN AFGHANISTAN FOREVER?
WHEN WOULD WE LEAVE?
>> WE ARE THE DEFENSE FOR JAPAN
AND SOUTH KOREA.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO DO THAT IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> OUR PRESENCE WAS PROVIDING
STABILITY IN THAT REGION.
DENIED AL-QAEDA AND ISIS WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA THOUGHT THIS WAS
A GREAT IDEA TO LEAVI IRAQ.
>> JOE BIDEN SAID THIS IS NOT
COMPARABLE AT ALL.
THIS ADMINISTRATION'S FOREIGN
POLICY IS THAT OF MISCALCULATION
AND UNDER-ESTIMATION.
IF THEY CAN'T HANDLE
AFGHANISTAN.
WAIT, THE TALIBAN TOOK OVER
FASTER THAN WE THOUGHT.
LEAVING BEHIND WOMEN TO SUFFER
CRUELLY.
WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH CHINA?
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE US?
THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY ARE A COMPETITOR, NOT AN
ENEMY.
TALK TO THE FAMILIES OF 4.5
MILLION PEOPLE THAT DRIED AROUND
THE GLOBE BECAUSE OF THE CHINA
VIRUS.
THIS IS A SANE ON AMERICA FOR
YEARS TO COME.
IT RAISES A MULTITUDE OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH ANY
ALLIES.
WE JUST TURNED OUR BACKS ON THE
PEOPLE WHO HELPED US.
>> AND THE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES IN
AFGHANISTAN WHO BELIEVED THEY
WERE FIGHTING FOR SOMETHING THAT
WAS NOBEL.
IF IT'S YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER,
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING RIGHT NOW
WATCHING THE ENTIRE THING GO
BACK TO SQUARE 1, THEY DIED FOR
NOTHING?
>> IT'S STILL SALVAGEABLE.
>> THIS IS A LOST CAUSE.
THIS IS A TERRIBLE THING.
PEOPLE THOUGHT THERE VALIANTLY.
WE GOT BIN LADEN.
WHEN DO YOU SAY ENOUGH?
DO YOU WANT ANOTHER 10 OR 20
YEARS?
THAT'S A LOGICAL QUESTION.
YOU CAN'T DEMEAN PEOPLE --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOU MISCHARACTERIZING THE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND.
YOU ARE RIGHT IF YOU BRING THAT
UP AND YOU HAVE BROUGHT IT UP IN
THE PAST ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PLAN.
I GOT.
I DIDN'T AGREE WITH IT THEN AND
I SAID IT.
NUMBER 2, YOU ARE NOT ASKED --
GREG, YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN
IN 2010 AND WE ARE LOSING
A DOZEN GUYS HERE AND THERE.
I GET IT.
THIS IS NOT A HOT WAR.
THIS WAS A HOLDING.
WE HAD INFLUENCE IN THAT REGION.
YOU HAD A GENERATION OF AFGHANS
AND WOMEN WHO HAD A CHANCE TO
LIVE THEIR LIVES.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WE
DID.
>> THE 20th ANNIVERSARY OF 9-11
COMING UP HOW LONG DO WE WAIT
BEFORE A TERRORIST GROUP
REGROUPS IN THAT AREA AND
ATTACKS THE UNITED STATES?
>> THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL MISSION
TO MAKE SURE IT WAS NOT
HAVEN FOR TERRORISTS.
>> AND THE 9-11 PULL OUT DATE
WAS AN ARTIFICIA